if you are doing a lot of listening and
reading or even speaking you will
encounter the most common 100 words 500
Words very very often however the
frequency declines very quickly and the
major challenge thereafter is going to
be acquiring the less frequent words but
the most common words they look after
themselves you needn't worry about it
and if your goal is to learn the most
common 100 words so that you can go and
start talking to someone you will find I
think in many most cases that you won't
be able to follow the conversation
anyway because the person you're
speaking to is not going to limit what
they have to say to the 100 most common
words